last day here in Chicago I'm excited
excited you know Nina's gonna love this
he was going to love this
all right good morning last day here in
Chicago slept in a little more than
usual needed the sleep better than my
presentation soon I should still hit the
presentation on time is Ashton Kutcher I
don't think I can do the meet and greet
at the end though because I have to do
my presentation shortly after I need to
set up you know I get obsessed with my
presentations I'm poor lot of love into
them I want to make sure that as an
impact the week is catching up with me
jun elevator beeping in a grab a freshie
smoothie for breakfast that was such a
pretty good yesterday and then head to
the convention center I have some
packing everything up so I don't have to
come back to the hotel so carrying this
and seeing the huge backpack mostly
because there is a little bit time after
my presentation by the means wouldn't be
able to talk to people gain one of my
favorite parts of doing these
presentations and coming out to events
in stock in people and helping them
one-on-one in the first session had an
hour and 15 minute wait people wanted to
talk to me and I feel bad that I can't
talk to them so somebody's come here and
paid money
you have to learn how to grow their
business and they want to talk and I
want to see but at least as much time as
possible so yeah carrying my whole life
with me and I'm gonna head straight from
the convention center stay as long as I
can talking to people and then and then
bring it home name is happy she's should
i want to sleep any shield and sleep
alone anymore so tonight will be in the
same thing the troublemakers are on
board yeah we're here at summit we had a
fourth member join our gang for a little
bit samantha who was convinced I was
Jeremy's cameraman I told it's the other
way around crane yes I was like I
manager okay let's say we're cutting
about cutting about recruiting the road
so charming British accent look at
something can get anything with that I
mean anything it's ridiculous
let's go watch match the pitcher Jeremy
and Kevin in the background we're
getting all met up with cameras and [ __ ]
I'm snapchatting they're clapping this
up oh they're doing away away away press
it's all grass
alright session is over can't go to the
meet and greet this time and I gotta go
to my presentation so excited looks like
here we are this is my group 14 ways to
create a steady stream of new clients
I'm set up getting ready to speak he's
tweeting something else not about my
speech something else but it's coming
it's got me the family yeah I gotta show
some love to end and so audience is
coming it's starting to fill up that's
gonna be me on stage this one is not
recorded like the first one so you
didn't come you missed out stage 7th
come next year alright so we just
finished a session couldn't record it
you guys have fun yeah I was a good
session bank Joey we had some great
questions afterwards we want what what
time was in there it is 1254 1254 we
started at eleven so an hour talk in an
hour of talking after the talk yeah
we're gonna grab some lunch with my new
friends and then head back out to
Toronto okay we got garden station
grilled chicken I don't know about that
oh ten Dory we got Indian what's the
blue one short rib tacos with kimchi
slaw this is a tough one they are out of
tacos I didn't really want to tacos
anyway but we had the Mexican wine of
the tacos okay chicken tandoori let's
see they still have some let's go get
some food ok we are done lunch it is
almost two o'clock I wanted to have
lunch with the people who are watching
the session
instead of just hanging out with the
VIPs all day long those guys are boring
meet entrepreneurs this is Kathleen it's
going to be my ride back to the airport
we had a guy join us who was in the
session the other day I want that some
questions over he's I think we kind of
lost the table instead of talking about
the reason capital and I fell back
because we kind of descended on this
woman who sit in the table alone and we
surrounded her and filled the table sort
of talking entrepreneurship but anyway
hopefully she enjoyed okay so while
we're walking tell us how believe nation
about your business okay my business is
gorgeous one GH o are jus one and it's
about
confident within your
self-esteem and self-confidence because
we all aren't we are all about feelings
and emotions because when we go to
adversities what's the first to go your
inner your inner strength
products will help you to build the
inner strength in beauty and so what are
we what are the products so what I have
is a fashion line a fashion line and
accessories so right are you wearing
some where's my gorgeous one accessory
well actually I have your wife up here
ok it to the crack Nina and Eva's gonna
love this he was gonna love this i'm a
newbie right now so started really
started all right where can people find
you were they going well right now
website twitter i will try this what
does one that mom but it's coming soon
okay gorgeous one calm stay tuned check
it out we're staying by you have to get
one more shot in the camera before we go
let's do it again here in and no out
there you go like that you gotta
remember one that's like in and there
you go that's it baby in style ok guys i
will see you soon
yes I had a great time off to the
airport so here we go I thanks guys I
want you guys to meet John who was that
my presentation just gave me a million
bucks ok the first million is the
hardest now it's all all downhill from
here thank you so much it's where you
from Taylor 16 Louis what's your
business real estate investor I'm in a
dream what can people find you they can
find me at the Delian air at gmail com
the Delian air at gmail com and I don't
love it secrets of it here we go secrets
of a deal in air John Lee yes 11 Robert
Allen wrote my forward good to me
committee thank you so much too I'm
super excited because we get to jaywalk
in chicago now with the local we got two
crosses one two three four six planes a
six-lane six-lane street we're going to
jaywalk I'm feeling it
love it let's do some jaywalking make
some rules okay so Kathleen is gifting
Nina some small these are liking
leggings they're not for me the friend
Nina they're very colorful right where
them from hers off the pleasure
that's a challenge Nina the challenge
you gotta wear the salsa class if it
fits I think you think it'll fit his
Eagle is pretty small all right we'll
give it a shot give this shot not I
might have to try it that's scary I've
never won Vikings in my life but if I
were to wear leggings this would be what
I would wear the blue shirt cool ok
we're going to hop in the car and hit to
the airport okay she'll chicago traffic
is crazy but we had a good ride good
talk fun times I'm now here at the
airport and I'm going to check in
hopefully catch my flight and get
something to eat
I made it through lots of time got it
was thick with Nina has been a while
since I checked in so just want to say
hi see what she's doing get something to
eat see what this year we got a
McDonald's some other stuff I don't know
we got a big headache so I've got a
going to decompress it's gonna be a lot
of decompressing later on today in
me tomorrow I go crazy and then
wind down being the introvert that I
have some close to my gate and yeah fly
home hope name is a bit look at this
list of all the fights that are canceled
or delayed it's crazy but the only ones
that are on time is Toronto feeling
super grateful I'm gonna get some food
extended outside
Mickey D's
and hopefully board in 45 minutes so I
got big mac
and I just notified that i forgot my
plug in my connection
I see summer because I was too busy
chatting with people and
so hopefully going to overnight it to me
so I have it tomorrow
use my laptop cuz they don't have power
lovely guys this age stuff so awesome
Amanda huge shout-out to the best too
good to be true weird the layer of
thunderstorms looks like it's going to
be at least an hour and a half but the
flight that's supposed to come in hasn't
even left yet so later we shall see I
have to go misogyny neck just like to be
happy hopefully it comes in traveling
crashing hard got a huge headache all
because of the weather I was talk to
Nina on facebook but I had to shut the
computer because felt super nauseous so
I'm on the hunt for some advil I can't
find that I'll get a starbucks
Frappuccino sugar and caffeine get
through keep it through there is a big
line outside of starbucks but I have
some time to kill
close my eyes for bit
combination of that plus the Frappuccino
plus how will the biggest back to the
weather
getting better feeling better and it
gives almost cons we're excited and it
looks like the plane is closed I hope
get on and go home and see me so the
latest update is we're not going to get
out until eight fifteen well the plane
is supposed to be here it is 15 tell
them that when we're actually hit on we
were initial asleep at five thirty and
it's
basically three hours late we'll see
we'll see I'm feeling better that makes
a huge difference the pilot is now
waiting with us in line and I feel like
that's a good sign I feel like the means
are about to go he doesn't look too
happy nobody's really happy but yeah he
look it's a good sign get hunger again
back at mcdonalds got to get something
for the flight hungry living for hours
so this time buttermilk crispy chicken
what's interesting never had that much
been American things I'm going to give
it a shot till they delayed again we're
supposed to get on at nine o'clock so
what i got here at three something
supposed to take off at five thirty and
now it's not even till nine what the
good news is the crispy chicken oh the
buttermilk chicken pretty solid if it
was in Toronto and I ate in mcdonalds
and we're probably gonna for Maura so
feeling good feeling good they switch
their game again so now everybody is
moving to be three the collective groan
when longplay it's a long delay right
how long has ease delays and I've been
coming out of Atlanta 150 hours post
lead I hadn't get here till eight
o'clock now we're going for be three at
least a mile and other end on the whole
corridor we gotta walk people are pissed
people are pissed finally boarding the
plane got here at three thirty ten
o'clock we'll finally
pick me up I landed in toronto oh so
excited we we got on the plane and SAT
there for another 45 minutes because I
messed up somebody seat they gave
somebody an extra ticket it wasn't
supposed to be on and so we just SAT
there and then when we landed in toronto
the flight crew wasn't ready for us so
we SAT a couple feet away from the
tarmac tarmac the bridge cuz they
weren't ready for us so I don't know
what time it is let me see it's late I
supposed to get in and eat something and
it is one in the morning Wow Nina I feel
bad for her she gotta wake up really
tough well good news is I get to see
Nina so go find her okay I ran I ran
through customs first one up to playing
ran through customs when I am delighted
Nina's go find her let's go find her
let's go find her there she is or she is
heard in front it's Nina look it's Nina
it's Nina hello hello what do you want
to say i miss cute we got to get Nina
home into bed to wake up early that's
okay you have to work early tomorrow
watch I do too but I feel bad for you
thank you for joining if you need to
believe or whatever your onward is I
will see you soon